welcome everybody I'm Arne Milstein
director of Stanford's Clinical
Excellence Research Center and welcome
to this this panel discussion of of
those brave enough to innovate innovate
in health services innovation in in
services of any kind or not for the
faint of heart the several you know
categorical problems number one they are
rarely if ever subject to any
intellectual property protection so if
you come up with a better mousetrap it's
a it's often a matter of time before
somebody if it's working
rapidly replicates often with more money
than you started with secondly they're
notoriously hard to replicate so you
have a service model it's one thing if
it's a if it's a simple relatively
simple service model and as you're
trying to get a somebody who's on the
night shift at Motel 6 to operate in a
certain standardized way that's that's
one thing trying to trying to manage a
diverse team of clinicians some of whom
don't regard themselves as anybody's
employee is something else I've
assembled today a group of those who are
not faint of heart
they have plunged forward in the into
the world of of health service
innovation and and in every case have
have had the good fortune of making
substantial progress innovation is is
little difficult or challenging for me
to talk about since most of my life I'm
about standardization and replication
and process improvement these days but I
did give some thought to it I always
been the operations person and actually
I was the CEO of hell springing out the
CEO so it was my job to take the
brilliant ideas and make them live in
clinical practice which I find somewhat
more difficult than thinking of the idea
thus i subtitle my talk where brilliance
gets crushed by reality
I wanted to talk about three examples of
innovation in delivery service and the
first one is paradigm shift then about
adopting and repurposing and then just
some kind of common wisdom or what I
call that no duh solution I wanted to
begin by talking about a delivery system
that I ran across in my context of
health spring in South Florida in the
Miami area called Leone medical clinics
and it was very interesting
high-performing organization as I was
around it more I realized they never
talked about any of the things I knew to
talk about in health care they operated
differently the key turned out to be an
epiphany that their leader bin Leone had
and he had been in the business a long
time and knew all about managing cost
and turnover time of rooms and and all
of the things we look at but it came to
him he says that Disneyworld that the
reason this business didn't work was
because it isn't about managing cost and
it's not about managing care
it's about patient loyalty it was just
the notion that if he could get patients
to be loyal to his organization he could
invest in their health care status this
is an all capitated system he could
invest in their health care status and
there was plenty of time to recover that
investment cost if he could count on
them being there 10 15 20 years so that
notion then led him to the concept of
the patient's experience of that
organization and to really a career of
obsessing about making sure that
patients experience was consistent exact
and perfect and you would talk to him
and he'd say there's five things you
have to know about my business patient
experience patient experience patient
experience patient experience and he did
things that I've never seen done before
his employee training
people are actually former its this is a
Cuban system so everything's in Spanish
but a former Spanish soap opera star and
some cast members and they actually
train people around the notion of how to
hold your body how to act how to convey
so that you present the common
experience even when you're not feeling
like it so it was that kind of shift to
to focusing on what the patient wants
out of it
he also said that people like me look at
things that for patients are inside
baseball and he described going to a
ball game most people are there for the
beer and the Sun and the fund and
they're really not carrying how fast the
ball is being thrown or how many
strikeouts they're not keeping box
scores so the notion of seeing the world
from the patient and it turned out to be
probably the most effective business
from all the objective measures that
I've ever been around
both profitability but also the quality
scores were off the charts and the
complaint file was zero in in the so I
wanted to talk about the innovation
process there was this realization that
led him to this new paradigm that if we
can retain patients and then that would
drive his profitability so he totally
changed the business model the second
one is when I was at mhn we were
behavioral health service company we had
this requirement the Fort Worth Police
Department had decided they needed to to
outlaw smoking anywhere in uniform and
he where near the building
in the jail or in patrol cars so they
needed a police department people who
were twenty thirty year veterans to go
cold turkey over a two-week period and
then they were going to begin enforcing
the no smoking rule so one of the things
I took from that was do not drive in
Fort Worth
during that 30-day period you do not
want to explain why you ran a stop sign
to somebody who'd been going through
smoking withdrawal we had a and it was
an impossible situation because these
are policemen they are out in the field
they're in their patrol cars they are
working 24/7 shifts and we were supposed
to provide group support for the smoking
cessation handed it off to clinical
psychologists we had who was
particularly adept at technology and he
came up with a solution set of
essentially adapting a conference call
methodology and running groups by
telephone therapy groups by telephone
that the policemen could log in and out
on based on where when they had time
yeah when they were sitting in patrol
cars and so forth and we ran that for
about eight weeks did individual
counseling support all on the telephone
and got really very spectacular results
in that the way we measure that is
generally the the smoking non-smokers
after one year and we had like an
eighty-two percent persistence rate
which is very high for smoking cessation
programs very innovative use of existing
technology so the adopting and
repurposing using all my slides and then
the third thing I wanted to talk about
was I was at a I'm doing a lot of work
with patient-centered medical home and
one of the common wisdom things we know
I work with poor people right now is
that poor people aren't able to utilize
computer portals and the like because
they don't have computers in their homes
I was at a patient-centered medical home
in Seattle and they were telling us it
had been harder to get that population
to it to understand what was in it for
them but that once they figured it out
they were as active users as the non
low-income population or the regular
population
and it turned out that the secret was
they all carried a computer almost every
single patient including most of the
children had one of these and they had
simply adapted cell phones to the
patient portal operations and were able
to provide communications to the
patients and then patients began finding
other ways to use other things like look
at their data and so forth either doing
internet connections through cell phones
or even in a few cases public libraries
and and the like so it was struck me as
an interesting innovation of grabbing
something that that the patient already
had in their hand and I'm sure we're
going to come up with an app for that
and if not you can get to work on it
because we need it
you know what I thought I learned about
innovation from this was that the best
results come when you ask the right
question and almost all of these
innovations came about as an answer to a
question the second one is the
innovations that seem to make the
biggest difference started and ended
with the patient not with the
technologist not with the provider but
with the impact on the patient and the
third one is that it's only valuable
when it's accompanied by disciplined
execution back to the ops guy but when I
mention Leone and their focus on the
patient in the fact they spent tons of
money on making sure that experience was
perfect some people think that sounds
like a warm fuzzy organization it's not
it's extremely disciplined in how they
make sure that experience is the same
every time
and so that disciplined execution
follows the innovation and that's what
creates the value so my current question
which I think if you solve this question
for me you'll have to generate lots of
innovations yes if we know what to do
and we do I have been involved in
patient
centered medical home advanced primary
care practice for a long time I can tell
you we predictably get 10 to 15 points
drop in email our run rate when you let
primary care actually do what primary
care needs to do the question is why
don't we do it and solving that problem
what are the things that keep us from
doing this right and in innovating
around that I think will be the next set
source of innovation note says as Mary
was talking and I was not there might
have been a few places where it might in
terms of your digestion of this it might
be helpful for me just to briefly
elaborate when Gerry referred to the
Lyon example of being Cuban he was
referring to a Cuban American section of
southern southern Florida not literally
in Cuba and it was interesting was in
Jerry was then responsible for taking
that model and replicating it in
radically different cultural
environments such as rural Tennessee
downtown Houston places where uniformity
of culture and population were very
different secondly for those of you who
don't know what ml R is
ml R for any for any delivery system
that has either a global capitation
arrangement or something close to it in
the way of a shared savings formula what
the insurance companies basically wants
to know is what percentage of the total
premium being paid in for the patients
who are taking care of is eaten up in
healthcare expenses either doctor fees
hospital fees are drug fees and so a 15%
reduction in ml are it means the amount
of money that the health insurance
company is paying out for care after the
innovation is 15% lower per person per
year across all types of service
categories so it's a it's a very big
gain if in the United States we could
reduce American healthcare spending by
by 15% did you know it multiply that
times three trillion dollars I'll let
you do the math Tom Lee
great well hopefully I just approach
this from the panel it's a little bit
more informal in terms of conversation
but just so I have a little bit of
context of the audience can I just yeah
show hands for people who are here to
learn something about healthcare
services just kind of for their own
understanding is that kind of where
people are and then how many people are
doing something or interested doing
something entrepreneurial and healthcare
services ok so it's a good mix I applaud
the latter half for shorts it's a brave
world to kind of attack out there in
health care service innovation it's
traditionally not the sexiest place to
attack certainly coming from Stanford
there's many other options to look at
and all I can say is it's where the core
fundamental transformation is needed so
we need entrepreneurs in this space but
it's also equally difficult and I think
there's a lot of people tried and failed
and you know it's not a very attractive
space and it's a difficult space for a
variety of reasons but to give you a
little context about what I've done and
what we're working on one medical group
I'll give you a little bit of background
in context as to kind of my journey and
may kind of inform you about your
journey and also there's some
generalised points that Jerry makes that
I think are resonant but you know
briefly I'm trained as an internist out
of Seattle in Boston and it was pretty
clear as I was going through the
training system despite the values and
the rhetoric of medicine that we weren't
delivering on the promise of patient
care and it was not done through ill
intent it was done through ill systems
systems that are financed and organized
in ways that are antithetical to great
patient care and so there was enough
people complaining about it I just
figured somebody had to try to figure it
out and I knew there were enough inputs
coming into the system it's not an issue
of resource you know we're spending more
than any other country per capita and
the outputs are so poor so there's some
inherent and flaw in the system if you
take a look at the the system at a much
more macro perspective and it's
inevitably inefficiencies right it's
transaction and efficiencies overhead
inefficiencies and kind of misalignment
of what organizations are doing to
deliver what people
which is healthcare so I began my
journey as a completely naive physician
so I can relate to the physicians who
are you know kind of that Jerry
mentioned that are not used to working
with administrative types because it is
a very different world it's a world of
scientists a world of people who are
completely motivated on the patient
values but then trapped in the system
that isn't really work for them so I
understood that I had no idea of the
business world and I think that's where
the insight really came in to how the
healthcare system is structured and how
irrational it is so kind of through this
process of discovery
there was this raw belief that just
enough waste in the system that if you
came up with a more sophisticated
business model and kind of people system
to deliver the care that you wanted to
do you could kind of disrupt a system
from the inside and out so that's our
approach is to take the dollars that are
in the system but repurpose them for
better use and you know for most people
who are reasonably well-informed about
the healthcare system it's a volume
based system it's insurance driven and
third-party reimbursement driven and so
therefore the system is doing exactly
what is incentive volume and
unfortunately providers over time have
developed a high overhead in their
practices to not support that and so
they have to increase their volume even
further so that's why we have the system
today it doesn't work for anybody so our
approach has been to cleanslate the
primary care model there was always an
inherent public policy belief that
primary care should lower total
healthcare costs and deliver better
value and in the practice of care it
makes the most sense when I have
patients who know me over a long period
of time they can email me a quick
question I can answer them without
having to ask them what their
preferences are right you know Facebook
is powerful because you know your
friends it's not powerful on in itself
it's a shorthand for extending the
relationship so what we decided to do is
clean slate the model and build it
completely around the patient along the
lines of Leon but with a very different
intent which was to scale and that's the
other kind of challenge in healthcare
and of a
and particular services you know there's
great models across this country one-off
doctors that are doing great jobs around
this country and then large systems like
Kaiser that are doing great jobs the
challenge has been why haven't they
scaled and so we wanted a scalable model
that can attract capital that can
attract great people and build a
software system around that that allows
us to deliver higher quality care at
lower cost so that's kind of a basic
premise one medical group to see for
those who don't know is a high-touch
kind of practice it's a primary care
group practice we offer same-day
appointments you know longer visits with
your doctor you can email your doctor
you can you know mobile text you know
you can schedule your appointments to
your phone or online you know very basic
things that are well known to the system
but we actually do it within the
insurance system and we've worked that
through lowering her administrative
costs and been able to kind of offer
that value back to the patient so we
lower our total administrative costs
give back to the patient in terms of
patient encounter experience and then we
ask that patients support our kind of
practice model by supporting with a
nominal fee of a couple hundred bucks a
year so it's very affordable it's
intended to be a skin of the game a fee
rather than a concierge practice so
that's kind of what we're about I think
just some highlights and themes are the
most kind of obvious thing to kind of a
consumer oriented view is not
necessarily the way it'll get deployed
in healthcare so as the business models
are the way healthcare suspense is very
distorted and so you have to kind of
disrupt the natural incentives the
economic system and the payback is much
longer so you have to be patient
associated with that but I think those
are related to Jerry's comments
but the reason is I wanted to sort of
combine what I can say with what I can
show and I think the the particular
points I wanted to make are innovation
isn't about a point in time it's about
it's about creating sustainable change
over time and hence it has to be both a
function of the idea you start with but
also how the idea evolves because the
other thing about healthcare is that the
environment is so dynamic so I think
that the challenge is going to be how we
can live with
you know credible ideas make them
scalable make them sustainable but also
make them flexible so the leadership
issues are pretty profound when we try
and think through that so I just wanted
to I'll just tell you a little story
that basically just grew out of the
Sinister conversation we had about ten
years ago we were sitting around and we
said you know like we do pretty well at
Kaiser Permanente taking care of people
that have chronic health conditions what
have we started a disease management
company was sort of the same question is
Tom that we take care of eight million
people in the Kaiser regions but you
know if we learned anything that we
could actually translate into providing
care for chronic conditions in a much
harder larger market you know like how
hard could that be and that sort of
started a journey that was again trying
to leverage things so we've been pretty
well recognized for trying to think
about how care for people with chronic
health conditions could be packaged and
and then delivered me as a service that
could complement and extend the work
that clinicians were doing so you know
it sounds sort of hopelessly naive now
it was naive and actually going into
these things with some naivete sort of
is not a bad idea because it actually
allows you to not know the answer going
in so a lot of innovation is being
willing to listen to what's going on and
think about what's going on we did have
a core strategy which really boiled down
to much in light of what we heard
earlier today that it was about figuring
out what the right thing was and then
trying to make it easier and making it
easier is very much sensitive to context
so within Kaiser Permanente there are a
variety of ways that we can make things
easier systematically and we went into
this thinking well you know that must
work in other places too so we did
create a company even creating a
company within a place like Kaiser
Permanente it's kind of an interesting
exercise which is probably another whole
discussion that we won't have but we
also had in a sense what was a
ultimately problematic opportunity to
test the idea about what this company
would look like for delivering disease
management services using an internal
client one of the Kaiser Permanente
regions it did give us some advantage to
actually get our feet on the ground and
test what was going on but it also sort
of perpetuated that what works inside an
integrated delivery system like KP would
actually be credible outside the place
like KP now the relevance is you think
about all the things that are coming
along now about payment reform about
changing systems about assuming the
doctors can play well together you need
to actively test those hypotheses
because there isn't a whole lot of
evidence to suggest that doctors play
well on the outside so if you're gonna
create accountable care organizations
think about where there may be places
where physicians collaborate now but
also realize that there's probably a
through the looking-glass phenomenon
that says that what works there has some
principles that you can carry forward
but you're gonna have to be really
thoughtful going forward as you go so
one of the the things that I did sort of
naively back when we were running our
programs within KP is we contracted with
one of our research centers to evaluate
our programs and to help us understand
if we were actually making a difference
and this is an interesting article if
you like you read it when you read the
title yeah I'm your takeaway we'd be no
they don't save money why the hell do we
do this if you actually read the article
what you find out is it compared to
trend there were several hundred million
dollars worth of savings the quality
improved for about everybody that was
there but the way that you get this
published and also the way that you end
up getting your next grant is to make
statements like this doesn't save net
dollars all of which are true but again
the issue was to understand what the
marketplace is looking for and the
marketplace was actually looking for
something it might be a little bit
better even if it was a segue into
curing not necessarily the all-time cure
this also was amplified both by in
banded hope through Medicare Advantage
CMS got into the disease management
business whole-hog structured in in a
way that looked like it would reveal
powerful answers by running it as a very
large trial and then the industry got
all excited about this look like a huge
opportunity and the expectations weren't
fulfilled in the final in the final
analysis didn't reach the cost-saving
target so though if you actually again
read the paper there were fairly
substantial learnings fairly substantial
business opportunity created the
Medicare health support was seen as a
failure so here we are implementing a
disease management company and
environment we're publishing our own
literature that basically says it
doesn't work Medicare comes out and says
this really sucks and so you know it's
kind of like whoa you know how hard
could this be
well you know the good news is that
there were some other things going on
too I'm the employer was actually
reformulating the value proposition and
they were saying it isn't just about
paying for services it's actually being
an active participant it's supporting an
incentive services and they began to
understand that it also that a huge
amount of what they were looking at were
patients that had chronic health
conditions so the market was changing a
little bit and the concept was changing
a little bit from being around disease
management to thinking about how we
improve the health of population and
then places like Safeway began to really
start thinking about how do they
actually almost become surrogates for
health delivery of not health delivery
organizations and began to increasingly
ask who's the infrastructure support
that can help me create healthier
workers which is a little different
value proposition than the question
about how can you actually improve the
care for people that have diabetes but
the delivery services are very closely
aligned and fortunately we were able to
recognize that there was a changing
environment but that we had capabilities
that allowed us to support a
market-based opportunity part of it also
the ledge is saying okay we got to
rebrand this sucker we've got to think
we've got a bit clearly differentiate
this so it's something different it's
associated with Kaiser Permanente but it
isn't types of permanent if you want to
Kaiser Permanente join Kaiser Permanente
please but if you happen to be in a
place where it doesn't exist we can help
bring this and we also had to think
about what the portfolio of services
were so at the core of these are the
ability to actually support behavior
change often through a coaching
encounter but there are a variety of
other ways to support behavior change in
the end of
Savior change was to support people in
making better decisions through shared
decision-making and to be able to
support employers and thinking about
where their particular population had
opportunity and delivering services to
met without and then to promote health
that again wine very closely with
employers and it also meant that our
customer base evolved from being our
original thinking about being small
regional health plans to largely being
huge employers that had the need to meet
reach many employers at the same time
good news is there's actually a fair
amount of literature validation that
it's work sorry one of our strategic
partners health dialogue has a very
large randomized control trial that was
published in the New England Journal
that shows that this stuff works you
can't change behavior
it's not necessarily about changing
healthcare you know this is this is a
modest activity in the midst of all of
healthcare which is also important to
keep in mind what your scale is and what
your scope is and scale has a dimension
of not only how many people you touch
but are you trying to solve the whole
problem all at once or you're trying to
create a meaningful intervention that
you can actually scale across a lot of
settings so the branding has changed
dramatically
- really - thinking about this range of
services as supportive of wellness and
condition management being focused on
the person who has the disease's not the
disease as the person has which is a
critical change and how you think about
framing - think about who the target
base is and then for those of us that
are old enough to remember we still
snuck disease management and in the
fourth paragraph but it's also to think
about part of the brand is to link to
but not but not totally mirror things
that are done within a place like Kaiser
Permanente so if you just sort of
musings and how I think this could
translate into guidance one of the
learnings for us is that you know you're
real familiar with where you start and
you got to realize that almost always it
will be fundamentally different than
where you start so adding integration to
a marginal system is fundamentally
different than adding march and all
value to an integrated system and a lot
of the things and this is going to be
important as we think about a lot of the
things that have been promoted in health
reform that are based on what's happened
in settings that are fundamentally
different than the ones we're trying to
change so there's a reason why primary
care Doc's
specialists don't play well together in
most of American health care because
they're not intended to do so so if we
have to think about how we actually
understand what are the incentives that
are being driven and think really
closely and then think about what are
the ways that we can actually change
that I'll come back to the comments that
were made before you know ultimately
relating just to the patient is probably
a common thread that will take us all
the way through because it's ultimately
the patient's money whether they're
getting it directly or not getting it in
their check because it's going to health
services and being able to relate this
to the needs of the patient at the macro
level is important as we'll see it gets
more important as we go down it's also
to realize that you really have to keep
very close eye on the people that you
choose to work with and and realize that
they may have a shorter haul picture the
you know the evaluator we use the way
that they actually promoted things to me
was kind of silly because it wasn't like
we hired them again and you know in
thinking about you want people to be in
this for the long haul with you and
think with you about how you actually
frame and share information so it is
important to be able to be flexible and
purposefully and purposely diversify
what you're doing and choose your
partners really well but also realize
that if you're on a path where your
partner isn't getting you where you want
to go or where you think the market
needs to go you got it rid of them
a really critical issue is in dynamic
markets like this creating change just
is is only the first dimension of what
you have to do and the issue is how you
actually sustain change and the way that
you sustain change is to change pretty
dramatically yourself so the trick is to
change in sequence with the market so
that the leadership issues are really
pretty profound and we've been very
fortunate to have leaders who can be
grounded can execute but part of
execution is to always be do something
next year that's different than what you
were doing this year because the
marketplace is going to have changing
expectations and you only get there if
you are thoughtful in that way and in
the last part about this is just that
coming back to the patient that you know
health care service is frankly an
oxymoron in most of American health care
I mean health care is the lack of
service it's it's a burden
and so thinking about how to reduce the
whatever the verb would be but making it
less of an oxymoron is really critical
and I and I think that the challenge is
for us as clinicians or as people who
are trying to design these systems to
realize that health is extraordinarily
personal and almost all of the knowledge
base has been derived for collections of
people or populations and it's about
trying to think about how do we actually
create personalized services so patient
centricity is sneaking in there's a lot
of there's a lot of thinking around that
I think the genomics industry has done
this huge challenge area Jennison huge
favor by by sort of pointing towards the
opportunity to focus care in the
individual but going forward care for
the individual is going to have far far
far less to do with the genome that it
is around other things that make us
individuals and I think that we heard
this morning talking about preferences
and value supporting people and choices
there are ways to do that systematically
but in order to do it well
systematically it's much more around
mass customization than it is around
cookie cutter
coming up with a solid way so I think
that the going forward you know
healthcare.gov is a great example of how
things are changing I think that you
know medical homes a COS and exchanges
their what we're going to be innovating
within that's the environment where
successful innovation is going to be
tested
you know what's going to go forward what
does this mean for a place like a Vivien
well the question that I have right now
is you know who's the infrastructure
provider for the medical home in the
absence of somebody who can bring
predictive modeling who can bring
registries we're at risk of building
several hundred thousand little homes on
the Prairie and that won't necessarily
help us to improve either service so
you've heard examples of how that's
playing out but I think that you know as
we think about how to create
personalized accessible services there
will be the need for people to supply a
whole range of infrastructure and I
think it'll be an interesting time so
thanks very much
so while you're digesting those
presentations and thinking of the
questions you'd like to ask them I'm
gonna ask the panelist to sort of
briefly address a question that occurred
to me as I listen to each of them speak
it's its keys off of Paul's last comment
that it can't be there's got there has
to be an underlying reason why so often
health service is in in in in health
service in health care delivery
benchmarks so poorly against other other
forms of human service my intuition from
when I was a clinician was that it has
to do with the fact that that that
patients are so appreciative of what
you're doing for them it's easy for the
people who are who are providing that
relief to sort of get into the the
mindset of patients as supplicants
rather than patients as as customers and
people who's you know who's who's who
deserve outstanding service you know
each of these each each of these are
going to each of these these innovators
you know had to had to think about how
though they differed in their objectives
they had to think about how to how to
transform the the frontline clinical
workforce that was interacting with the
patients into into a force that that
that that felt differently that was
willing to recognize that even though
they were providing very very helpful
services they also had to be what I
guess we could simply call very nice in
the process of doing it I know in the
case of the Lyon example the the place
that mr. Lyon started and like Jerry
maybe to reflect on this was he reasoned
very simply this was you know this is I
refer to this as sort of lizard brain
thinking he simply asked himself where
where did he feel most wonderfully
treated now that he had this new
objective of retaining you know from age
65 on the eternal loyalty of these
Medicare Advantage patients that to mr.
Lyon was serving in his primary care
clinic and the answer that occurred to
him was when I stew when I'm
a ritz-carlton hotel people could not be
nicer and and that was that turned out
to be just the beginning of of mr.
Leone's solution to how he went about
training a clinical workforce to be
extraordinarily and consistently nice to
to these seniors who were their primary
care patients
similarly in one medical and I mean I
the reason I've stayed with one medical
is it's wonderfully convenient and it's
there's no waiting when I get there I'm
treated well it they they're there
they're familiar with with my record
that that doesn't happen normally in
health care
clearly there's there something that the
tom is doing to sort of structure the
work and also select who works there in
order to make that happen and last but
not least you know I can't imagine
something more difficult to do than as a
third party operating from a telephone
from some off-site location change
people's behavior at work not only in
the health domain but also in terms of
their their role and productivity as
employees I mean just it seems
impossible that you could build a
relationship that would lead to those
kinds of changes over the on the phone
in order to be successful in that
business Paul had to solve that problem
so maybe you could each just you know in
a minute or two reflect on you know and
as you eat of you had a different change
objective but they all very much
depended on the customer feeling treated
very much better than people are
typically treated in American health
care how did you do it
what we began do was actually look at
what the customer wanted and I know that
sounds silly to say that but I've been
in health care all my life and really
that was not high on the equation we
talked about customer service so answer
the phone call and three wearing these
or last smile when you answer that kind
of thing
but we really didn't spend a lot of time
asking what it is the patient wants what
we found was the patient wants not only
the nice treatment but they want comfort
they want to feel guided and they want
certain expectations that matter to them
Matt every time and when we were trying
to replicate what Leone was doing in
rural Tennessee we were charting patient
satisfaction almost on a weekly basis
you could run the chart one of the
things we found in that particular
population was when you said I'll call
you back with your lab results for them
that was a contract and when you didn't
do it you know for all the reasons and
busy office practices that you don't get
around to things when you didn't do it
you could see that satisfaction plummet
because you you had now that was not
important to the doctor it was not
important to the delivery system nobody
was going to get paid but it was that
that contract that trust relationship
that would get broken and it was
probably the most difficult thing we did
was have to work on how do we guarantee
how do we create an organization that
meets those expectations every time and
we had them quantified the expectations
quantified in it it sounded pretty easy
in the lab but to get the behaviors from
the staff to get the organization
changed one of the reasons we often
didn't return the calls was the
supervisor there wasn't authorized to
okay over time
so we had to change the organization
around yeah I mean I think it's there's
a lot of you know literature out there
it's you know tone through the top and
building systems that support it and
hiring good people and we just do that I
mean most people don't do that they say
that but they don't do it and there's a
big difference between your actions in
kind of your words and so at the end of
the day we're in executional business so
I can say the customer comes first
you know easily but making the customer
truly come first hiring people who care
about it equally giving them the degrees
of freedom to deliver on that promise is
a very different thing and so it's a lot
of tactical details that are intangible
and it's what makes service industries
interesting compelling and you know
already gave this interesting context
about how protectable they are there is
a protecta protecta ball element whether
it's culture or kind of the people
systems you have you know Starbucks is
pretty easy to copy business I would
argue right but they figure it out a
people formula and a business model that
works and so similarly you know there
are other kind of great service models
that figured it out but only a few at a
scale of a level and so we focus on
actions in addition to words but more in
actions well I think a big it's
obviously about relationships on one
level but it has to do with sort of real
Evelynn relationships and you know the
relationship you have with a provider
doing your appendectomy is different
than the relationship you have with your
provider managing you over time and I
think that a lot of health care has been
late to get that that you can treat keep
you know and and it's I think that
respect is one part of it but it's also
respect manifested in a whole lot of
different ways so it's realizing that as
a busy professional means well just your
question for you how long what's the
average time for a primary care visit in
Northern California
so think about how you answer that
because if what if you're a mom who
lives in Walnut Creek and you're gonna
come see a provider in Oakland and you
got to drop your kids off at your
mother's house you got to go through the
tunnel you got to park a car you got to
wait in the waiting room you're gonna
see the doc for eight minutes and then
you have to reverse that how long is the
primary care visit and you know what's
you know do you feel respected during
that period of time you know you might
feel intensely respected during that
eight minutes or somebody's sucking up
to you but is that respectful of you as
a person as a professional and there are
other pieces too or when you come into
the office and they make you repeat what
you've told them 17 times before how
much does that make you feel like they
remember you and that they respect you
as an individual you know I think people
should become intolerant of people who
are incapable of remembering what you
did in the last conversation and then
they bill you for it and then they call
that reimbursement for their time and
Winsor reimbursement for your time so I
think they're a whole there's a whole
lot of sort of nested issues the other
part though is a relevance issue where I
think that you know the reason that
health care is getting it finally is
that I think what health care is figured
out is that most of the things that
actually drive health care costs don't
have anything to do with health care
they have to do with health and they
actually have to be out sourced and
cross source to the patient of those
that are going to be success in making
any impact on the kinds of things that
mostly impact people's health down so I
think if there is a recognition just as
a business driver it's almost a
competitive thing to realize if you
actually want to be impactful on
people's health you have to form a
relationship you have to respect them
you have to have their information
available no I'm asking people to come
up to the two mics to ask questions
maybe I could ask Paul to elaborate and
one thing that I'm dying to hear from
him and that is it's uh I can you know
it's hard enough to build a relationship
that conveys respect and caring
face-to-face but one over the telephone
how did you go about
tackling that problem you were here the
telephonic disease management they've
never met these people before how do you
how do you how did you induce that well
I think part of is also you know
relationships are built over time and
relationships are also solidified by
exactly the things that I was just
remembering about understanding what's
important to you being able to support
you a lot of times the people you know
we talk about how could it how could a
nurse on the phone ever come close to
what a doc does in the office but you
know what that nurse on the phone is
gonna remember everything that happened
the last time that you talk she's also
gonna remember the name of your dog or
she's gonna remember what was important
to you the last time and you think about
what makes you actively contemplative
around thinking with someone at working
around behavior change and then contrast
that was sitting in the waiting room and
reading that you know Jennifer and Brad
are still together in the waiting room
for God's sake you know so I mean you
know it's thinking about how you can
actually support and it's realizing that
behavior change is little bitty it's the
tiny steps there were earlier and I
think that oftentimes the the ability
over the nurse over the phone using
people that are specifically trained in
coaching not in telling but in
understanding and listening being able
to reflect that that can often form a
more durable relationship than the
pseudo relationships we create in the
office thanks Paul thank you my name is
Bill Evans I'm well I'm here because
this particular session because I
actually work on the device side of
chronic disease management and I think
you can't obviously do that for very
long without realizing that it's very
much a systemic issue and I really want
to just ask the panelists do you think
that though the two sides you talked
about the service model differences that
need to change and I think clearly
there's some issues that need to change
in the device side do you think there's
enough integration doing there's enough
communication going on between those two
different parties in that equation so I
tell you the question has to do with how
do you begin to conceptualize a service
wrap around a device since inevitably
but in diabetes obviously it's a it's a
it's a huge spend area but it's it's not
you can go if you have a few ever just a
device centric approach you end up
creating things that are good for your
business model as a device producer when
really probably from from a public
health policy point of view it's much
more about some of the service model
innovations we're talking about here you
know I'm well aware of what kaisers
doing in that area for instance and I
just think I wonder if there's enough
communication between the two sides to
enable the the most successful
innovations to take place you know I
guess my response would be that if you
looked on you know if you tried to say
have we been able to see a major
movement you know in this way no but but
you know but but the the other point is
that I think that these these
innovations need to be disruptive and
they need to be they don't you don't
want to start out with it too big
because then it gets killed off before
it has a chance I mean I think the whole
point is if it's small and there are a
lot of islands the other the other piece
that I think is really important is that
it has to be parallel process there
won't be a single thing that will work
for everybody there have to be a whole
lot of different innovations in a given
space parallel processing rather than
thinking there's gonna be one thing that
we'll see really work so I mean I think
M health is a wonderful metaphor where
like a year ago who knew what M health
was and how many people were actually
thinking about it but it's a wonderful
weep to realize that if you're trying to
reach people at home using information
technologies what's your odds of getting
to them over to the computer or getting
to over the phone well it's kind of a
duh now but but you know for so much
time we talked about you know how the
elderly don't use the Internet
so I think that it just changes as we
begin to see the different innovations
the some we'll be stickier than others
Gerry Tammany like 10 I think it's a
great question I mean I think there is
going to be a need for device companies
to move in a little bit more in
alignment with where providers will be
but today that's just so lagging right I
mean I think the only large delivery
organizations like Kaiser probably have
the best potential to kind of create and
shape that market but I don't think it's
happening to the extent it could we'd
love to but we're still too small so but
I do think that looking at how devices
transform the care experience within
that lens is a very different approach
and could be pretty innovative at the
right stage but I think it's financing
and usage issue yeah I think one of the
contributors to the overall chaos in the
healthcare system or non system as it is
is what I call the many-to-many
conundrum I have lots of insurance
companies who feel they ought to be
stepping in and managing patient
physicians who feel they should be
managing the patients hospitals who feel
this is their community they should be
setting the tone and in all
right-thinking well-meaning but it
creates gridlock and so when you start
introducing innovation it seems to come
in slices this innovation will only
apply to 12% of your practice and yeah I
don't know how we break through that but
somehow we've got to be able to have
clear channels and responsibilities so
we can actually do innovation know if I
could and I think Jeremy this is a good
point I mean they're also needing
they're not even need to be only the
point innovations they need to be
bundlers you know they need to be ways
that these things actually begin to be
accessible to practices without having
to choose all the different pieces and
you know there will be different ways
that happens maybe IPAs make management
firms it may be you know health plans
may be companies but I but I think part
of what we're gonna see is there will be
aggregation so that you know a physician
doesn't have to sort out all the
different pieces they can access the
service in and that's where I put in a
plug for the comparative effectiveness
the having to again the many-to-many
having to originally do the research on
everything you want to bring into a
practice who are a set of practices is
just daunting so the notion of having a
reliable standard that you can say I can
rely on these claims and it
will fit my population is something we
don't have so we have to rely on
salespeople Michelle so my question has
to do reflect around social disparities
and what's gonna happen with the
Affordable Care Act which all of a
sudden now is gonna cover thirty-two
million more people and and as I listen
to these great presentations on how
service innovation is going to leapfrog
around innovative um health or emails
this is going to be a population that
doesn't have access to that and I'm
curious as to how each of you are going
to approach this large population with a
quite a difference in access and social
disparities so just to elaborate in this
so the the the most people who are going
to now have health insurance who didn't
have it before are what's referred to as
the near poor people who just didn't
quite make make the old Medicaid
eligibility cut-offs
and Michelle's right they you know they
tend to have fewer resources and and and
and will need will need customized
approaches if they're gonna benefit from
from the enhanced coverage how many
hours do we have I'm working currently
with an FQHC which is a community clinic
organization it's one of the largest in
the country so it's a good sized
enterprise but a core part of their
mission is to reduce disparities in
healthcare outcomes for Latino and other
minority populations so it's it's kind
of their reason for existing and it's
very complex
the one thing I've begun to learn is the
people are not as access limited as you
might think that they can't embrace and
do embrace the technology and again they
kind of skip the home PC but we're
finding that everybody's walking around
with a cell phone and we were slow to
get that
when we asked for people's phone numbers
we got a home phone mostly they're
disconnected question the number we need
is your cell phone so but that's part of
the cultural relevancy of figuring out
how you work with specific populations
and how you make that accessible and
it's not always high-tech we have two
more questions but anything to add the
thing that we tend to migrate to
technology as a focal point for how this
could all happen but I think that you
know it at KP and anybody else who's
ever tried to implement technologies
whenever you make a big mistake it's
usually not vetting the technology it's
understanding the social processes that
go along with using the technology and
so it's sort of fun you know so the
trick here is don't let your IT guys
design the solution for disparities it
ain't gonna happen but its involved them
in the discussion and then they there's
always to me the dominant thing is how
you figure out whatever we call workflow
and the professional setting but how
people think how they act how they how
they get to services and it gets the the
power of the Promotora for instance in
different cultural contexts so a lot of
its gonna be to figure out you know who
do people self-identify with who do
people seek respect from how can they
actually have information exchange in a
way that's durable and a lot of times
that has much more to people talking
than having a device in between and I
think that's where a lot of the promises
please introduce yourself my name is Xu
Bruin I'm a physician and a student at
Stanford
my question is geared around a one
medical kind of a system so in a system
where patients are actually allowed to
text physicians to ask questions or
schedule appointments it is very
convenient from the patient's point of
view but looking at it from the
physicians point of view it also puts an
additional burden on our already
so-called busiest professionals in the
country how do you plan to manage for
that while optimizing it from the
patient's point of view and providing
good service yeah so this is kind of one
of the key concerns about
access right you improve access what
kind of access you know you don't want
text messages about you know random
things so I think the key issue is is
forming a relationship that's built on
trust and access but feedback on
inappropriate access so there's a couple
things we budget the time to manage
appropriate communications digital or
physical but inappropriate digital or
physical encounters get feedback back to
the patient and it's a dialogue saying
this probably didn't need you know an
email or this probably didn't need a
visit or you know in the future you can
do X Y or Z so it's it's a language and
a learning process that people need to
develop new norms for and it's
behavioral and so that's what we do so
it's also very subjective right like
there is no hard and fast line so how do
you matter how do you kind of decide
where to draw the line is it the line is
to err on the side of the patient so if
the patient believes that they're having
a heart attack and we know they're not
come on in right we'll see you and if
they now there is the other side where
we're a little bit paternalistic on the
clinical side if we think they're having
a heart attack and they don't think
they're having a heart attack well force
them right we will we will you know
after their behalf so there are two two
elements to having that but but by
opening that communication channel
allows you to have that dialogue rather
than not having a dialogue and it's it's
it's a human communication between both
the consumer the patient and the
physician and the providers on our team
and and we trust them to figure out the
right solution at the time you know
another thing that we found at KP where
you know here in Northern California
forty percent of the primary care
context now are virtual through either
email or by phone I'm mostly by email
and the other advantage that clinicians
have have found is that the asynchronous
nature of those unloads some of the
tension of the office so there's also in
for workflow it also means that if
you're if your service delivery is to
respond within 24 hours that means that
you can actually go to the soccer game
you know you can you can be home for
your kids you can do the email at some
other time
- they're in bed um you know then and we
and it's also to think about how you
have accountabilities and workflow so
that you don't we just work people into
the ground to do it but we found it
gives much more flexibility on the
clinician side to actually take care of
a practice than forcing everybody to
come in for a bit of business thanks
Paul I'm Eric beer from the Palo Alto
Research Center we've talked a lot about
the patient experience in this panel but
I'm also very interested in as a patient
when I do need treatment how can I be
sure that I'm being seen by someone
who's qualified that they're up to date
on the latest possible treatments that
that they're using the latest
information that I'm getting as good or
better value than I could get from some
other organization basically what
information do I get from your services
and your networks that I'm getting the
value that I want to be getting may be
let any of you answer that maybe just
one because I realize we have more
questions building up I mean I guess I
can take the liberty some say no longer
work for Kaiser Permanente I'll tell you
my personal view is that physicians
should be accountable for being able to
reflect the service that they deliver
and I think that that means that they
should be personally accountable for how
they perform and they also have an
accountability to work with a system
that will give them the supports that
patients need so so I mean if that means
that we have to have reporting down to
the individual physician level on how
they do in a range of things like
satisfaction and other things I
personally would favor that that's again
my personal opinion ponyville elaborate
what I think were some of the additional
implications of the question so for
example the you know patients want to
know that that that when it comes to
being referred to a specialist versus
something being handled by a primary
care doctor I think what I would want to
know as a patient is that I'm not just
being rapidly turfed off or a problem
that the primary care physician could
solve for me right there and they are
competent to do so that they would do it
on the other hand I also don't want like
to have the confidence that that if I
that if the right answer based
you know current clinical guidelines and
the capabilities of the primary care
doctor that the right answer is I'd be
referred out I'd like to have the
assurance that that's gonna happen right
now that's a sort of a very much a gray
zone and opaque zone for you know for
patients you kind of hope that it's
happening but you really have no way of
assuring that that you are being
continuously matched with the right
level of clinical skill any thoughts as
to how you know how we might better
assure patients that they needn't worry
about that that that that if they yeah
I'm thinking of probably in the world of
Kaiser Permanente yeah the issue often
occurs with respect to quaternary
services you know things that you know
we don't want Kaiser Permanente to do we
want them to refer to UCSF or UCLA or
Stanford or whatever I think it's the
PatientsLikeMe thing so what you'd want
to know is what happened to the last 15
women who wanted to know about having a
bone-marrow transplant for breast cancer
in 1996 there were some you know quick
some questions like that and you know
and I and I think that people will have
access to that kind of information you
may very well find out that none of them
ended up seeking a bone-marrow
transplant because they felt that their
questions were adequately answered so it
also makes the point that you have to
understand that what the metrics are and
I think there's a lot of development
work that we have to do around
appropriateness of service not just
quality of service and appropriateness
we'll have a patient dimension and a lot
of clinical quality dimension is that
for example is that a dimension that we
might expect forward you know a society
responsive Medical Group in the future
might might want a report you know to
their customers as to that this is
something they monitor and that when
patients you know do need referral up
there they're getting it because it
obviously is a you know source it
particularly among probably especially
among you know very discerning customers
it's a source of concern well and in
don't misinterpret my comments cuz I'm
very sensitive what was brought up
earlier that we don't want to set up the
practicing doc as a single point of
failure either so I think it's very
important that we you know that we
respect you know
you know panel size and a variety of
other metrics and the other thing is it
isn't you know service quality isn't
just letting the patient have whatever
they want it's about having a
relationship in a dialogue and about
having boundaries and I think to me it's
I want to know that I'm in a healthcare
system that can understand the boundary
but then can respect my needs as an
individual within the boundary not the
cookie cutters me into one particular
process but I don't think we have the
metrics to reflect that yet okay but I
think you said the key word which was in
a system of care so you're you're not a
doctor
you've been sent to a different doctor
but there is a system of care and you've
learned to trust that system of care and
that's been built through your
experience with it now you're treated
your questions are answered
is that notion transformation that we
have to make away from care being a
practice of art by individuals to
systems of care that we can sort of
define and be able to say I trust that
system or I don't my name is Rajiv Kosh
and Walker Bosch healthcare my question
is to the panel that as you are talking
about innovation in healthcare service
delivery watch stuff how do you feel
about our how do you think we should
approach as an industry to integrate the
telehealth services or Home Care based
services to improve patient engagement
patient's overall health population
health management and who should be the
driver for that I mean other than the
CMS whatever they're doing and you know
we heard talk Park talking about this
morning but from the when the providers
like Kaiser Permanente or the new
innovative designs I want medical I mean
how do you guys think that we should
proceed with that well I've spent a lot
of my life dealing with disconnected
disjointed healthcare well-meaning but
where one insurance company uses a nurse
based call panel and other insurance
company sends health buddies home yet
another payer does something different
primary care physician doesn't know
any of that's going on doesn't get any
of that back in the medical record of
what's being found patient comes in and
says some lady called me and and so the
patient ends up kind of conflicted
around that and I know it can be done
well but for the most part it hasn't
been done well so that be my first in
foremost point is whatever we do really
needs to coordinate and integrate as
part of the process in a consistent way
rather than be in sort of independent
silos of each other and that's that
many-to-many not bad people that it's a
bad system you know I think the twos
ways the weekend to build on that ways
the weekend you know extend
relationships and so part of this is to
not have it as a way to cut into the
practice of your primary care doc or
anything but it's to it's to create the
opportunity for the doc to bring
services to patients they wouldn't have
had otherwise so when I when I think a
lot about you know in the Medicaid world
access to specialists it may be much
more credible to create access through
vehicles like telehealth than it will be
to necessarily be able to use bricks and
mortar based services and we shouldn't
enter into this with a prep with a
premise that that's going to be worse
care the question is what would it take
for that to be better care how can that
support the primary care clinician about
creating access they couldn't do before
that can expand that relationship and
then the other thing that we've
encountered is that if you actually do
the telehealth visit while the patient
is in the row and while the primary care
doc is in the room there's also a
continuing education opportunity for the
doc to get direct learning from the
specialist so there are a variety of
ways you can connect the dots it might
not be possible by sending the patient
all over the place yeah I mean I think
the key is just the economics of it and
having the population to justify that so
if you're accountable for that a broad
population that's just bridger
geographically it's fantastic but I
think it's there's only so many models
that'll support that our models at some
scale going to support those type of
technologies last question thank you
goomy's random actually one of the
residents here and a question about
through one of the big elephants in the
room with all this is sort of the
we have in America in terms of you know
the fear that you we have as clinicians
of missing something that somebody's
telling us on the phone they say they
have a fever or something that you know
always ultimately may require additional
workup
have you noticed that when your business
models you've noticed that this rapport
that you build with your clients that
you've had less incidents of sort of
cases that have gone wrong where they
haven't been willing to sort of undergo
aggressive litigation against your firms
or is it still something that remains on
the back burner where you're very
conservative on your telemedicine or
with your phone calls that if something
something gets brought up by a patient
that you all immediately bring them in
to get evaluate at the ER and has that
caused more costs or has that I've used
has there any internal analysis been
done on this from a litigation
standpoint as well as from a cost
standpoint cause here down and I think
we attribute that to being able to
amplify again the pieces you've put
together the logic chain is down at the
very end is that patients are much less
likely to sue if they feel that they
have a relationship and the relationship
or the things that we talked about
before but it's not just having you know
a friendly warm hug from your doc it's
about being treated with respect it's
about having your information there and
it's also you know the ability to
realize that your doc is a person - so
excited get all those things sort of a
amplify in my mind thanks for your
participation please join me in thanking
the panelists
well